citizens of the reject Nation it is John it is
Tara Erickson back in the saddle once again hi
to check out a classic Adam Sandler joint neither
of us have seen the water boy and that all changes
today Tara how you feeling hi hi excellent
me too listen up if you want more of these
reactions if you want more Terra on the channel
send the love in the form of a like leave that
on the video helps out very much also subscribe
to the channel and when you do ring that Bell
most certainly ring the bell for us ring the
bell for Tara Erickson's Channel as well as
La eats and drinks which is her online food
Excursion oh yeah baby I'll take you around
Los Angeles Eaton and drinking La eats and drinks
with me go on the journey absolute vodka and hey
before we hop into this one last thing why don't
you join us over at the patreon if you want to
get the full experience of the water boy see
everything that doesn't make these reaction
highlights it is a blast sync up with your
own copy patreon.com the real rejects we've
got tons of fun stuff over there so without
further Ado let's watch this [Music] thank
you so much Sean something like that cut you
out just pretend like I did it agua hombre
[Music]
Bayou Blues I have never been to a
swamp oh you should go seeing a lot
of swamps in movies never been to one a
lot of great swamps across the country
comment below with your favorite tell
me the favorite swamps I'll go oh whoa
damn that is a an aggressive title smash from
the outside it looked like it was run down
that's how I like to wake up every morning
I'm gonna get a few good hits in before we
start reacting for the day sure sure he does
you've got a good looking football team
maybe good enough to add another national
championship trophy to the old case the only thing
better than a crawfish dinner is five crawfish
okay I'm gonna try and do the rest of the
reactions in the coral fish it's a gold accent
nah he's gonna be a hero just you
watch look at this contraption
a plus it's clean it's cold and
that's what I call high quality
all right the highest quality H2O what is
it [__] doing here he does a great job
disrupting my football team you
idiot 18 years of this is enough
18 years yes 50 calls for you you're far
oh pretty sure he has tenure by now yeah
Cajun County I love me a Cajun sauce oh yeah oh
my God Kathy Bates is in this all right let's
do this got character actors Galore I bet
oh my God that's where I want to go can you
guys please tag where that building is that's
where I want to go now you'll be able to spend
your days at home where you belong I could
try to to get another water board job for a
different team don't you raise your voice to me
Bobby Boucher I don't like confrontations I'm a
Virgo who told you you was a Virgo that that that
girl who told you Virgo's avoid confrontations
[Music]
I went down to Georgia Louisiana you
seem to be sweating quite profusely
perhaps you might need this services
and experienced water board yes put
yourself out there how old are
you kid 11 12. I I'm 31 years old
I bet that was a trailer moment oh God what
is that guy's name he's huge so this is where
they strip the ball from us whoops he
has time to pick it up and dust it off
and running for a touchdown before our guys
even know what's going on David Spade's voice
oh no this is Henry Winkler I am inquiring as
to whether you have the need for an experienced
Waterboy on your upcoming season nice suit
there's a flanker lined up to the left once
the quarterback has the ball he fakes to the
left no fakes to the right he doesn't think
he pretends to fake huh I don't know where
I am the same hang on here hey come on
Prime Time honor boy
delicious water it's good this is much
better than what I serve oh thank you I
will do it for free just promise me that
you will never distribute the content of
that drug to any human poison puts hair
on your chest oh hey oh nice oh God they
have to swap it that's good oh wow hey
you know save some plastic yeah okay
uh just have the defense run
sprints I'm trying to decide
oh man now we're with that kind of
[__] where are we going this way
I'm determined to be able to decipher what he is
saying I feel like okay it's no way what is better
cold that the H2O is purified it's good to use
the heating Source story no my mama always has
better safety than sorry my mama says that too I
don't know Mama's the same uh-huh cooperation I
need it now used to be an assistant coach at
some big football school but he had a mental
breakdown or something seems like he might still
be having it it's a really prolonged breakdown
[Music]
all of that precious water you're only
hurting yourselves yeah Jagged is out
oh my God you're gonna have to drink
out of that dummy check this out
yes he happens to be a finely tuned
athletic machine and I ain't gonna
have him hitting the head by some
idiot water ball do you understand me
oh core memory you gotta defend yourself
here Bobby they didn't find it yeah tune
the athletic machine I'm not telling you to go
on a shooting rampage whoa thank goodness stinky
they're all going to laugh at you oh yes oh yeah
I would be honored if you if you play football for
this team my mama won't let me play no football
you and I want to talk to Mama mama said my
Mama said Mama said Mama Mama say Mama say
Mama [Music] I just love the Devil Went Down To
Jordan as like their establishing music for home
yeah let's talk about Bobby playing football you
see my boys too delicate to be playing foosball
and whatever you call it with them Gargantuans
Gargantuans my husband Robert he decides he's
gonna go and join the Peace Corps if he got lost
in the middle of the Sahara Desert he died at the
dehydration oh you know when I was your age my
mother told me not to get a tattoo of Roy Orbison
or is it like on his butt I thought he was
gonna show us but mama don't know won't hurt her
yeah I knew it oh my God I knew it you're a comedy
genius I completely forgot that would be part of
the conceit of this like a few minutes ago I
was like how are they gonna make a whole movie
we're getting a little old you can share
mine you try it on man see if it fits all
right okay friend oh a dick don't listen
to him no former Water Boy Bobby Boucher
is going to play some linebacker for
us now I want to work with the offense
I want to work with the defense special
teams go with former Fran do some laps
I want that to be my internal monologue just on
a daily basis I want you to tackle Casey like you
did Gee yesterday right now right now go does he
know about this does it matter come on Warrior boy
like a like an awkward nice hug you know
a physical sport boxing hockey who's your
favorite wrestler insane I'm gonna have to take
Captain insane I want you to do to Casey what
Captain insano does to the bad guy this
captain and say no A Healer face though
come on buddy
[Music]
I want you to think about all those mean people
they're going to be your tackling fuel we're
going to use them to play football tackling fuel
I want you to visualize and then attack not to add
you having a much better day today coach Mr
coach I feel like you could just yell at him
welcome around stupid to do what
your coach tells you no no what
all right there we go all right all right
can you do this for me every single game
can you do this oh not only will I do
it for you I at yes yes I'll do it for
you [Laughter] that was that was very funny now
is there anyone here tell me why most alligators
are abnormally aggressive I know the answer
to this question raise your hand anybody oh
mama says that alligators are ornery because
they got all them teeth but no toothbrush oh wow
alligators are an enlarge medulla
oblongata that is correct noted
you can tell me where happiness comes from
happiness is from Magic rays of sunshine I
come down when you're feeling blue that's sweet
Mama's wrong again Mama's an idiot Mama's right
something wrong with his medulla oblongata [Music]
last demonstration his glasses flew off
his head kick off another year of Mud
Dog football with the weight of a 40-game
losing streak on their back 40. wow see
what's great about going to a school with
no football team is you're never defeated
I feel bad about lying to my mama I
wonder what she doing right now [Music]
I'll bet you 50 bucks throws touchdown
pass on the first play Clint Howard
[Applause]
ah clean interceptions you owe me 50 bucks
you said it was going to be a touchdown pass
you crazy [__] I love that they have
the one guy in fake teeth and I think
those are just Clint Howard's actual teams
yeah yes watch where you're going needle
hmm do you want to win like that guy has a
huge medulla oblongata but a not so huge um
[Applause]
nice sacking them
there we go baby [Applause] first
time they've scored in six years
dude like guys uh be nice to him I mean
he's making you win games no one's that
mean that long we're tied at seven
with 30 seconds to go in the fourth
quarter on an upcoming play I'll be
playing with your mama tonight 62.
like a screen pass hey
thank you what the oh so that he could tackle him
was that his thought are you gonna catch up buddy
that's some martial arts right there nice
job [__] you just lost us the game would
you please still be my fan no get away from me
okay okay buddy nice blues music down the mood
oh Fairuza bulk just got out of jail I heard you
were playing football yes well I I we live up by
another day we live up by on our day if we go and
get something to eat and catch up on things Mama's
not a a big fan of restaurants or uh of of me
going to one if you'd like on a Sunday afternoon
there's a a a grill with a charcoal biscuit
you want me to come to a barbecue yes that's it
mm-hmm a grill with a charcoal biscuit I
hope you like what I did to y'all lawnmower
she's awesome hell's yeah you need
to come do that to my lawnmower
oh my god oh no
I don't believe in that sort of thing
personally astronomy is one of the many
tools of the devil yes correct yes thank
you for saying that is in the star foosball
oh Bobby yeah Roy Orbison can't
they have a catch that gorilla would escape
from the zoo and punched you in the eye what
oh my goodness cover best cover what do you
think if Bobby did play football Mitsubishi
I don't think much of you and all your snotty
questions I'm quite Disturbed to see that you're
so interested in my boy I'm very very interested
in your boy oh okay did he tell you about a little
bedtime problem Mama I'm begging you don't that's
a sheep back there oh excuse me ladies I'm gonna
go hang myself oh no buddy no that that woman is
a devil and I want you to stay away from me you
hear me now you come on inside for that little
witch Castle spell on us oh but she fixed his
lawnmower I'm sorry Mickey Mouse such a cool
name gonna fix his heart by the end and it is
no bones no bones in that little alligator
the amazing 31 year old freshman set a new
NCAA record by sacking the quarterback
16 times Bobby Boucher is also the team's
Waterboy what exactly are they putting in
the water down at Jackson's Bayou Louisiana
oh yeah I bet you feel real dumb right now look
at you switch that burger out for a big old
plate of crow cut to him crying in the corner
mean old man first string quarterback Tommy
Gardner does not have a broken name excellent
that's great to hear her I forbid you to talk
to that enchantress she's the devil uh oh
she's the most beautiful woman in the world
she was the devil the most beautiful
woman in the world oh please don't hurt me
scramble on this quarterback though
I love you so much Mom I love you
oh I love you too yes finally a nice
football player it's gonna be a big party tonight
baby let's go here we go
this is that must have been a popping soundtrack
back in 90 whatever feel looser the pressure is
off and that will lead to a lot more victories
yeah that in a Waterboy getting 20 sacks a game
that too that water Diamond does look good
yeah we still haven't had test on amphibians
and reptiles next Friday yes sir oh my best
regards to your Dear Mama oh I see at this
party yeah what are you doing there buddy
and you are so cute is there a girl you're
seeing I I see a lot of girls I see a lot of
guys too I think that's sexy yeah there we go
it's terrible John the gorilla
they gotta catch that damn gorilla
not bad what molecule is that I suppose
I had to be moving on if I get you into
trouble tell Mama Mr coach client said
that what mama don't know won't hurt it
maybe we could ride home together in that Porsche
[Music] feels like one of those quintessential
like 90s yeah like her look yeah yes and just
I don't know that like energy it's a Vibe yeah
the 90s vibe that you're like I want to hang out
with her yeah she's got like you know obviously
you got like the craft like she can be the the bad
girl or you know like a formidable character but
you also can just fall in love She's sweet too
yeah because you're interested in astrology and
mystical stuff like that you might appreciate this
water from a glacier in Alaska wow blessed by a an
Eskimo medicine man it's cold yes it's always cold
that that's why it's so special wow that's cool
okay becoming a man today it would do I never
did that before that was your first kiss
and I bet it's the first time you've
seen a pair of these oh my oh my
goodness that is another voice for me and I
I appreciate what what you show me right now
the devil devil [Laughter]
I mean sometimes I just don't know why I'm bother
with you you ain't even a man ah Bobby Boucher is
doing great on the field not great in the bedroom
it's okay by the end water sucks [Applause]
now you've done it uh oh he's mad now better not
see one cup of Gatorade Gatorade is the devil
tastes better too idiot you're you're
drinking the wrong water Gatorade H2O
it really really sucks
[Music]
dude there we go you're learning boy yes he saw
boobs and now he's a winner there is a direct
correlation between the two absolutely it reminds
me just about how special this season really was
you [Applause] you we've got a young man who
has been so vital to our success and a wonderful
friend oh Bobby Boucher hey all right he gets
a little party was this the first Rob Schneider
you can do it thank you so much for being my
friends oh I just want a button that plays that
you fixing to tackle all of us can't get water
love and ask Greg I asked you a question dumbass
whoa whoa I saw your head off you can do it
God just head off yes we don't want this to
get physical right client this is not
how ambassadors for the University of
Louisiana's supposed to die so now you just
get back on the bus oh he damaged the coach too
assault with a deadly weapon get her a little
country ass out of here oh dang he's ready
Mickey's the best this is a transcript
South Lafayette High School and Cherokee
Place Louisiana it ain't no South Lafayette High
School in Cherokee Plains Louisiana this is a fake
oh my this is from the NCAA they don't think you
ought to play football no more damn it if you
didn't go to high school Bobby I was homeschooled
I didn't know I needed for as a fake transcript
if the water boy's a cheetah don't
change the fact that the real mud
dogs are gonna kick some cougar ass my
dog my dog my dogs my dogs my dogs okay
[Applause]
let's go let's go team I also like that the coach
smelt off to Waterboy dressed like a Dixie cup
oh he just has to stand there and watch yeah
sad the NCAA is going to allow you to play in
The Bourbon Bowl yes you just have to pass
the high school equivalency test everybody
hates me that's not true oh no that hurt
somebody made me look like a cheater I did it
I did it I did it I did it I did it
what he forged it why because it was
the only way to get you in I came into
my office I went under my desk I cried oh
oh boy he's not gonna be cooking chicken anytime
soon 20 years ago we were assistants
to coach Kavanaugh boy was I good
I would write these foolproof plays in my little
green notebook that I had [Music] him look at him
go coach Kavanaugh was going to retire me and
red we just knew that one of us was going to be
a successful splash of color Schindler's
Waterboy that was his green book [Music]
filthy Rock stealer are we in all that green
notebook you use right on him football plays
man well I need to show Kavanaugh that
I can come up with some good play ideas
through my place I need them
[Music] [Laughter]
don't forget to hit that notification Bell friends
next day fired me once he had my notebook he
didn't need me anymore and that's breakdown
happened I can't believe it myself I'm so oh
oh god oh I just hate him I hate him I hate him
a little uh Norman batesy over here okay
well you're gonna show him yeah you're a
man on Saturday and I'm gonna show everybody
that I'm not a dummy you got this you both
got this come on now what you reading
for because sitting there all grouchy
mama I gotta read this book and six other
books tonight or else I can't play foot
up toe you planned a foosball behind my back so
I can go to school school you going to school ugh
you gonna lose all your Fenty foosball games and
you're gonna fail your big exam because school
is the devil oh well I like school and I like
football and I'm gonna keep doing a boat because
they make me feel good there you go and by the
way Mama alligators are ornery because [Laughter]
see you learned something and I
like Vicky and she likes me back
and she showed me her boobies and I like them too
much but it's good it's all on the table it's
just a 300 multiple choice questions you have
three hours good luck to you sir I remember
scansron's boy there's a small town [Laughter]
that's what the meme is from seeing that as a gift
with no context a thousand times Vicky is the best
dude she's got she's got a memes
under her belt too yeah [Music]
come on Bobby
oh what your mama got sick this
morning oh she's in the hospital
what have I done slowed down version [Music]
she got broken heart because of me everybody else
in this town trying to meet at the job of a hat
mama is the only one who really cares if I live
or die oh she's a faker what hospital allowed this
oh my goodness that's a great cut too you got
the house to yourself no you made the hospital
look like home [Laughter] too because
he's like made it look like yeah insane
[Music]
oh [Music] assemble the Avengers
yeah get them together wow wow
yes all right best lives over here getting it
[Applause]
wish we had little candles in
plastic cups however they're
actually just shoved through plastic
cups all these folks are here tonight
to tell you that they're sorry and one
of them wants to say something come on
oh okay you're an inspiration to all of us
who who weren't born handsome and Charming
it's okay you're doing great [Music]
and how much you're playing football
means to this town but she can't hear
you cause she's unconscious oh go to
the window mama do the right thing
mama I was so bad mama you were right about
everything I've been a real knucklehead baby
you should have seen this a long time
ago daddy is that my daddy no no this
guy I dated before I met your father oh
you get on a shirt on his stomach Daddy
so handsome who's Helen that's my first name Bobby
oh oh my goodness I'm sure I had no problem
finding work so you can expect my next letter
to contain lots of money oh but sorry no
money yet Nolan's is an expensive city
to whom it may concern oh geez we have Grown Apart
over these last six weeks two loves in my life
big city living and a voodoo woman named
Phyllis oh ciao Roberto ciao I was so
scared you'd abandoned me too I've made
you abandon all those people who depend
on you but I can't hug you to myself no more
because everyone's seen how wonderful you are
you're not the devil after all
you go play foosball with your
friends yes yeah Red's got a couple
of solid early rounders out there hey
[Music]
I know their names they're just not right now
I Sports sometimes Madden no that was not John man
at least I would at least a name better than me
kickoff is a beauty [Music] oh you're gonna
run it okay nine yards deep come on [Applause]
damn they're showing no respect
for this team whoa oh boy oh boy
okay touchdown cougars they strike first
all right damn it off to a great start
yes yes
wow that's awesome yeah where can I
go on one of those Remember the Time
Bobby tackled the referee by mistake about
the time we tackle the guy from Louisville
and threw him into the stance is he supposed
to be like a sling blade parody I don't know
harder
showed up at halftime minute my
dog's won the bourbon ball you yeah
in a dramatic turn of events Bobby Boucher
just arrived at halftime and on a fan boat
Brett his mother drove right into the
stadium that's great right to the stadium
if only we could have seen that water
boy water or boy Rudy Rudy Sports chant
it's a reverse
nice yeah there we go fumble recovered that's
what I like to see knocked the Boop out of him
poop
[Music]
oh he's gonna do some play from the green book and
maybe the Henry Winkler will see it and it will
bring him back to life it'll like awaken he'll be
like that's my old play from 1972. [Music] what
is red bow you doing refusing to play offensive
yeah this is bizarre oh red is taking the water
boy out of the game by kneeling down three times
in punting he's going to make the mud offense try
to beat him the way they're playing today that's
impossible ugh that means coach Klein will have
to find another way to out Fox red please come
on think of that green book are you afraid of
Red Bull you [Applause] damn book yeah somebody
not a fatal and then attack that you told me
come on get your fawns on
that's terrifying oh
now this is what we're gonna do he's gonna come
here yes all right we've unlocked it let's go
do this [Music]
trick plays going let's get them shovel passes
[Applause] [Music] that's what I like to see red
is sending his best defender in as a running back
okay no no sir I'm gonna take matters into
my own hands you'll see bring it to the hole
meanie with an ey oh boy sound like a big
choo-choo train he does kind of sound like a train
[Applause]
compliment of Captain insano yes yeah wrestling
nice call back wrestling saves lives visualize
the ball kick it
[Music]
oh yes yes oh my goodness clear out of the stadium
foreign [Applause] yeah live your best life
Oh weird play what are they doing
love it dang switching it up [Music]
yeah there we go
battering around that was awesome [Music]
Red Bull you is steaming there Brad he sees
his perfect season slipping away [Music]
it's called karma Bobby Boucher is now on
the kickoff team last game of the year Brent
can't hold anything back now I know [Laughter]
[Music]
that was a cheap shot flag I'm not sure
the Boucher is able to get back up no Bobby
he just needs some water oh yes the Glacier
Glacier Water that's gonna save him [Music]
that's high quality H2O has a whole ass
Kip up it's gonna be hard to do in football
gear oh boy just need just needed some water
[Applause] you think that up all by yourself
oh man oh man back and forth I have an idea
for the last play the offense is going to line
up like this yeah you're gonna be right here
there'll be no tie here today coach Klein is
sending his offense back he's got a new green
book now buddy yours is outdated Bobby Boucher
is back on the field he is now playing offense
we know it's the last game of the season okay
do not bet him get away do you
understand me do you understand
me get in there I'm ready friend
let's do it Bobby all right [Music]
cool not Vangelis but but same Vibe
yeah Vangelis circus Sports Center
[Music]
love it love it is he gonna
make it easy gonna make it
it's a cool shot come out
[Music]
get them Sticky Fingers
well done
I do love the commentary there's so much
commentary on Sports is like pretty obvious
Professor colonel iest
[Applause]
he loves his mama [Music]
oh all right well deserved you're gonna become
a man good night this is the best day of my life
what was gonna happen tonight
you'll see you can do it
you can do it all night long I'm sorry you can
Daddy oh he was talking about you being
drafted by the NFL not going to the NFL
I'm going to stay in school and graduate the
hell with school don't be take the money you
and me could be oh she's gonna tackle him that's
great [Music] I hope he gets it from his mama
love it get him and you go on
have some fun becoming a man
oh that's sweet crazy belly they
got on his daddy there all right
come on you got all the extra horsepower
floor of that thing yeah come on now
ah that was cute that was cute that was
that was fun also what happened to uh
the guy in the beginning who was the first guy on
the team to befriend him and be nice to him he we
heard like two things from him in the beginning
he was like here you can share my helmet and then
like he wasn't he didn't say anything at all like
I thought I thought it's going to be yeah but like
why did it later why were they like friends I mean
like he's not like a huge character but he's there
throughout being like yeah you were still like
friends but I was like Oh I thought that he would
have a conversation with him that he would like
he would go hey man like listen like it's gonna
be fine like do this I got you yeah yeah you
know I think he will be like his his prominent
male buddy male buddy that we kind of didn't see
except I guess it was the coach like he serves
he does yeah I guess I just wanted to see that
a little bit you were in the relationship yeah
I just really liked how it was in the beginning
how nice he was he was like the only one that was
like it's fine man we can share my helmet like
I thought that was so sweet and I wanted them
I wanted to see more of their friendship yeah
yeah no I would agree with that for sure I mean
I I appreciated the the various relationships but
like yeah yeah there was a lot I know I don't know
yeah Vicki and the coach and everything so yeah
I think like a different version of the script or
blah blah blah whatever but I would have enjoyed
that too so right because I like that guy like
and I I know I've seen him before and I thought
he you know had a lovely presence yeah and he
had one gold tooth which I have always wanted
in my life why don't you get a little tooth I
I haven't I don't feel like I've earned it yet
yeah I feel like I have to reach a point where
I'm like you know like killing the game and I got
like independent wealth to the point where making
a choice like that it doesn't really matter to
the bottom line right you know so right give it
give it five ten years okay and then I'll go gold
I'll give it 20. thank you yeah for handicapping
me yeah yeah but yeah this was a delight like I I
you know like we've said you know what I realized
we made it through this whole reaction with Mary
a a drink of water I feel like we we failed we
should have happened here the whole time I have
my water in my shoe and I didn't drink and there
you go you go you got to make up for the both
of us now but like I missed a good amount of
like the Adam Sandler Classics growing up we just
weren't like a Sandler house and there's always
that debate going back for these movies of what
did you have to be there for at the time and what
just holds up anyway and I feel like there are two
lanes like sometimes they're Adam Sandler things
where I see him and I'm like I feel like I'm
just aware that it's you and it's and then it's
you doing your kind of stick or whatever whereas
I like a movie like this where he is committed to
a character and just you know sort of earnestly
playing the character yeah and uh and so yeah I
appreciate just the kind of yeah just earnestness
he he brings to something like this anyway yeah
I liked also the casting of Vicky I forget our
name but I really like her yeah she's great like
what happened to her where is she yeah I feel
like she still pops up and stuff but there was
that period of time where she was huge right yeah
she was like one of those like it girl like so in
so many things and two with that like edgy Vibe
and everything and I feel like Kathy excuse him
off I didn't get enough sleep dude and I
feel like Kathy Bates was also brainwaters
we're dehydrated we're dehydrated that's yes
dehydrated reaction and Kathy Bates was like also
huge at this during this time oh yeah I feel like
my bra was showing the entire reaction not like a
lot but a little so you know if you saw a bra it's
just I didn't know it was out yeah I didn't know
um it's okay yeah be a very innocent uh viewers
here oh really yes huh they don't even know what
a bra is I feel like they're gonna get mad at
you for calling them innocent uh you know they
can come at me in the comments we're making
it what are the Innocents gonna do apologize
run rings around you logically oh yeah yeah it's
one of those movies that kind of lived up to about
you know the expectation I would have had but uh
it achieved its goal it's fun it was delightful
it's got its raunchy elements and sometimes that's
not my favorite kind of Comedy it never really
bothered me here though like you know there there
are moments like oh you got the donkey drinking
out of the toilet that are like a little bit
obvious a little bit like you know haha you know
vague poop joke or whatever but for the most part
like I appreciated the earnestness yeah that's
kind of the word I come back to do you have all
these absurdly mean characters around him and just
like the sweetest ever guy in Bobby and and I mean
part of me got curious cause I'm like you know
they do address at least with him like you don't
have all like the you don't know social cues very
well and things like that and he's got the stutter
and he's got you know his specific demeanor and at
the time I'm like you know I'm sure this is just
like a character that he cooked up but two like
now that we're more aware of psychology I'm just
like curious as to like what people's thoughts are
you know on just the Aging of this character
because again it is played so earnestly and
he is so committed to it right doesn't seem like
it's some kind of flippant like I'm gonna create
this caricature even though there is certainly
height to it yes um so yeah it's like you know I
feel like this a movie like this can exist on a
slippery slope but it didn't feel too tasteless
in being that right like I mean today he wouldn't
be able to make it but like looking at it now it's
I agree with the earnestness yeah right yeah and
like it's there's so many characters laughing at
him but I feel like the movie itself isn't and I
think that's kind of the key like I feel like you
you might be able to but I feel like if you did
try to make this now there would be sort of a
different feeling or a different conversation
to have before clearing this to be what it is
you know yeah yeah a much bigger conversation
versus I think back in the the 90s was this
made yeah right really yeah it's got to be yeah
I mean I don't what is it is this 1998 that's all
it's been a lot of time in 1998 ladies yeah dang
yeah okay and I'm looking here and it says Bobby
Boucher is a socially inept stuttering and
somewhat mentally challenged 31 year old man
and it's like I am fascinated to on just to hear
how people think this has aged certainly given
just again yeah the way the conversation shifts
I and I do think that it avoids being tasteless
because the core of the movie seems like it's
trying to be compassionate towards Bobby and to
lift him up so you know and clearly he's capable
and can learn but also yeah it's one of those
things that makes me curious yeah and two like
I'm thinking back because a lot of these I feel
like I I wish I had my sports brain on better
because like Lynn Swann was in here and uh a
number of other like famous commentators and stuff
like that many of whom are still you know active
and and commentating and whatever today who you
know when I do catch football uh you know sort of
passing through rooms during the season you know
I will see those faces still and hear those voices
so I feel bad if I didn't catch you know this is
one of those movies where I think yeah even partly
through the reaction I was like I bet there are a
lot of like random Sports cameos in here because
obviously there should there must be oh yeah yeah
Adam Sandler had could get whoever he wanted in
the 90s early 2000s to be in whatever movie he
made through that I mean he got Jennifer Aniston
when she was on friends she did not need to be in
any movies oh dang right I mean she didn't I mean
Adam Sandler's great but I'm saying whoever
he wanted to choose from he could get yeah
like they dated heck yeah well she was she was
in that the movie and like the uh early 2000s
with him and recently last year she was in another
one for him there they've definitely been friends
since yeah but she's been in a lot of projects
with Adam Sandler he knows how to get the cool
peeps that's right you know people must like
working with the Sandman yeah and I mean too
you got I really enjoyed Henry Winkler in this
I thought he did a nice job straddling the line
again between earnestness and silliness giving
this guy such like a a Sad Sack genuine quality
to so many of the like goofy things they have him
do but also enough that you buy it when he's like
you know kind of getting over this hump with the
other coach that Kathy Bates did a really nice job
and and two like holding down that accent and and
making this character that's like an antagonist
but that you don't fully hate and yeah the way
she comes around like you know there's a lot
of stuff that you could yeah you can predict
about how the movie is going to go it's it's
classic in a lot of ways just the various sort
of random recurring characters Clint Howard uh
you got your Rob Schneider you can do it which uh
which this has to be one of the early instances
of that of them trading that Cameo back and
forth I don't know if it's the first one but
but yeah this is it's a fun time capsule because
I remember people when this came out being just
so much about it and kids quoting it and doing
the Bobby Boucher voice and stuff like that
it's filling in this this part of my my you know
memory that's been echoing for so long you know
yeah I feel like the only character that wasn't as
so corny and classic that you could see it coming
was Vicki's character because she could have
easily been a blonde hot girl that have been
that in my brain I'm I don't know what movie I'm
thinking but just like blonde hot fit girl in any
Adam Sandler movie that's like yay and she's just
like really cute and dumb uh except Vicky had some
like she's like I fixed your lawnmower to have a
V12 engine in it and also I'll kill these people
for you because I just got out of jail which
I adore like I love her character when we look
at it because it could very have easily gone the
other way and not have had as much of an impact
in the storyline like you could have easily just
gone I don't want her to be a cool badass girl
with like dark hair and just out of jail they
could go great we'll just supplement her with
like a blonde girl who's nice and sweet and it's
not gonna change the storyline as much right yeah
um so I like what they gave to Vicky like she
whips out a knife and is about to kill the
coach I just I love that all of those those parts
with her unpredictable for me I did not see those
coming the rest of it was like oh all right once
I realized I can't be playing this like they're
mean to him as a water boy for an hour and a half
right then I was like oh he's gonna play football
yeah after that you're like okay I get I get what
this is gonna be with him and Mom and stuff like
that but Vicky was the one that I was like oh the
stuff that's coming up for her character I did not
predict and I very much enjoyed it yeah they make
you like her and she is distinct from so many of
this so much of the status quo around him and
it has a very different attitude from all the
people around him so yeah it's like even though
she is edgy they do kind of make like an actual
character out of her yeah somebody that you do
want to see open up his world a little bit you
do want yeah it's like you know that could easily
just be requisite and like you only care so much
as like the the immediate moment of the movie
requires hopefully and achieves it was one of
those elements that had a little more flavor and
personality than I was maybe expecting it's like
they're both oddballs but in a in a Charming
way yeah he's so innocent he's so sweet and
naive and and you know he doesn't he's you know
clearly acquiring knowledge and I like that too
it's like clearly he's capable you know clearly
he's intelligent he just needs to be given the
opportunity to learn and uh and so yeah you have
his innate sweetness and then her innate edginess
but still that good nature between them and like
that was yeah that was like a character thing
that was interesting as well as amusing yeah it's
very much like elf except elf I think was executed
uh I lost you know I get where you're coming and
elf was like executed in a totally different way
um but it's very much like you know it's the same
character thing of like he needed some guidance
he wasn't all there right he's like elf and I live
in with Santa and then he meets uh Zoe does Chanel
who's a little harsher and then brings him to
the light and they get married and live a great
life it's like it's a lot like elf which I and I
love Elf so much that's one of my favorite movies
it is terrific it is it's probably the
most recent sidebar of all the crew
I can think of maybe one other but like you
know how like in the Canon of holiday songs
it's like you know after a certain point in time
there aren't really that many Classics yeah it's
like with Christmas with holiday movies there
aren't really a lot of like no this is one for the
all-time Hall of Famers you know like the Pilates
here and Elvis elf is one of them one and elf is
maybe not the most recent one I could think of but
it's damn near close it's stinking it's close and
even the other ones I'm thinking of I'm like I
don't know if everyone would agree with me where
I feel like most people would be like yeah elf is
a holiday classic elf Jim carries the Grinch and
um oh what's my other one oh then The Nightmare
Before Christmas is pretty cool yes yeah that
was a sidebar but we went there it's okay I'm
resisting Christmas in July but it's June it's
fine we're like 20 days early John it's okay it'll
be Chris we can do a whole Christmas reaction
can we do it in July sure sure definitely
maybe that'll work better than when we did
and I'm like I hope this picks up around
Christmas you know or maybe we can promote
it again in July oh my gosh but yeah Christmas
is July you should wait till the holidays John
I just couldn't wait I just I just could not wait
that's a great movie yeah yeah that's a super fun
movie David Harbor Santa all day every day um but
yeah I want to look out I want to get a list of
of all the the like famous uh players yeah the
Cameo appearances Lynn Swann Lawrence Taylor
Jimmy Johnson Bill coward coward coward Dan Fouts
Brent Musburger Chris Fowler Lee Corso Dan Patrick
Lawrence Taylor Paul that was the Big Show too
was insano I knew I recognized him and I've seen
him since then couldn't draw it to name but yeah I
appreciated that the film was extremely profitable
I mean it seemed like I mean Adam Sandler at
the time certainly seemed like yeah wow one
of the key you know certainly it was like his own
cottage industry him and Jim Carrey I guess maybe
like a Martin Lawrence or something like that
like you know guys who were like always coming
out with these big old comedies and everybody
around me three times a year right like crazy
yeah and everybody all the kids around we're all
seeing them you know it's like it's weird I have
the association just because everyone I know was
watching these movies when I wasn't so I I had to
be part of many conversations of people talking
about the movies and not really participating
because I was just like I can't I don't know what
you're talking about I have not seen such a thing
you know what's funny is that I was in this movie
in 2012 it's a feature film called waking except
Adam Sandler wanted to buy waking he liked the
script a lot and he was like but I can't go like
it's gonna have to be me and whoever I cast right
and uh luckily my my friend who wrote it and then
produced it Skyler Caleb um was like nope sorry
and so it's it's me and and Skyler and magsione
and a bunch of other people Tim Daley's in it
Sam Daly's and Jean Smart is in it hey uh and
uh every time I guess waking comes up I always
just think like Adam Sandler liked that movie he
wanted to make that movie but Skyler was like no
this is my movie like we want to make it but he
went to the the production company that Adam was
with I mean I guess it's Sony and something else
um but happy Madison a thing oh yeah
it does a happy Madison ding ding ding
ding ding to see this is where I don't
come from and Adam Sandler household or
where I'm like oh right yeah yeah
yeah uh yeah it's all good anywho
dang Sandler watches the movie and cries
yeah just once that could have been me
yeah yeah yep that's the thing that's happened
crazy story but we still got to do ADR at Sony
Studios because I think Adam was still like nice
well he's obviously nice but I think they still
were able to go through a different maybe an
indie production company maybe through Adam I
don't know but I got to go into a Sony studio
thing to do ADR and that like that bro they're
huge they're so big John it was so cool I bet I
felt super cool then I was like wow I would wow
you are accepted I hated ADR it's the worst ADR
does seem quite difficult yeah and uh it seems
like they didn't have to use too much of it here
there were times where I could hear the digits
in the background yeah but but matching lips and
then matching the the tonality of the scene like
yeah I do not I've done a little bit of ADR and
it is a it is it's a beast boy you're like I know
it's me and it's my mouth moving I cannot this
is I don't I can't redo it I can't can't do it
I'm trying and it's never perfect and it bugs
the s-h-i-t out of me I'm like I convinced one
director not to use a Dr one movie with the
scene that was outside and he's like you're
right we're just gonna do the regular we'll
just Juice It Up and I was like thank you so
dude you direct you slightly directed I slightly
did it because I was like listen to the difference
it's not that big of a deal this one is so
much better the fact that you get a little
environment in the background doesn't bother
me that much versus me doing ADR I was like
I'm trying to give you the juice here man I can't
do it the juice Kim couldn't do it John it's okay
because it's okay you tried I tried just like
the water boy he tried he tried all you can
do is try all you can do is try and every time
we cut back to your house Play Devil Went Down
this is an odd show I was like you've got other
music in this way like I I am obviously it amused
me I found it Charming but I was also like did
you run out of music button until you're like
we should just make this yeah just use the [__]
out of this queue that we bought what would your
song be if we went to your house ooh yeah John
give it to us or you could give like two options
yeah it's like what would you choose versus
what would it for like truly be yeah I guess
uh uh for whatever reason we are family comes to
mind if I if I imagine what it might actually be
uh uh if it was me and I was just wanting
my own home establishing music um let's see
um dang that's hard right really hard I wouldn't
know how to because there's every song at your
disposal and you're like I don't want to go with
something like heavy and badass because like
that's not what being at home is like you know
I'm like what's like a pleasant but upbeat song
yeah yeah
I don't know see the thing is when people ask
you to like name songs then you don't know of
any songs you can that me they're like what are
the I can hear the elements of what the song would
be then I'll get in my car to go home and I'll be
like oh it's these 10 songs yeah exactly you know
it'll just be five four by by gorillas what's your
what's your what's your home music oh I don't know
is there's a song that's like Witchy Woman right
how does it go Joan woman ah you're guessing yeah
I was trying to do like is there like a black
velvet song I love the color black except my
house is very vibrant John I don't know this game
is this question this song and we could Corner the
K-pop boom baby he's got it that's that's the tag
right there that's the Zinger yep but uh I like
the Louisiana Vibes the Bayou Vibes that was also
one of those things where it's like okay we got
this like just because they chose to set it here
we have all these random sort of Bayou flavored
gags and things and all the like alligators
they're eating like they really went to town
on making living in Louisiana it seemed like a a
real back woodsy experience yeah and uh it's funny
because also too talking to to friends of mine who
like live in areas of the South uh I also wonder
how like if somebody from there was to hear like
you know a Cajun accent or you know that that uh
you know that Lou that that that drone that like
very sugary kind of drop oh that's good John ah
dude I do appreciate Joel I don't think I could
do it you got you're halfway there though I'm
trying to I could maybe do Southern but it doesn't
sound like your drawl that you're doing so I can't
I can't do it it's okay study up come back yeah
but I always wonder what people who are like from
around there think when they hear these accents
and if anybody's like really like I bet Kathy
Bates probably like did her homework yeah because
she had like a real again like a real great grip
on that point she also won an Oscar sure right
yeah and I love that she's like game for yeah
for like yeah she's you know she's I mean before
we had character actress Margo Martindale we Kathy
Bates all right we still got Kathy baseball
we're lucky to live on a Kathy Bates timeline
hallelujah oh getting my hands on some nice
glacial water that's right someone's like what
is in that glacier water other than the the
innate chill yeah which alone I mean I love
that that came back I thought that was a fun like
McGuffin thing and two like the whole like yeah
the the the notebook they they threw down on the
Schindler's List slash later on Sin City effective
like we're doing the black and white with the
color yep um but I like the way they used it even
just as a visual joke and you got the afros and
everything using that tool of visualization you
know as something that the whole team can get into
in some ways like he empowers Bobby that way then
he starts telling other players to use that and
then finally Bobby comes around is like you should
use this visualization technique as well it seemed
like something that is it was nicely tied around
for this movie story but also felt like a vague
kind of thing that you might be able to apply to
an actual sport yeah yeah right or speaking event
yeah imagine them all in their underwear that
never works but like in this movie it would it
would it would yeah and uh and water always works
water always good for you the Lord's uh the Lords
yes wine I thought right he's um he turned water
to wine though John I feel like he was just he's
knocking him back and you know that's how he can
I guess he'll Heal the World heal in the
world yeah well guys we are healed by your
presence joining us for this reaction and
yeah leave us your thoughts on the movie
any other movies you would like to see us
check out certainly any other Adam Sandler
joints you might want to see us react to If
we haven't seen him yet uh leave that like
on the video subscribe to the channel and hey
last but not least let's do a little picture
Daniel the Gallagher Daniel now
look I know we usually talk about
your pharmaceutical background wow
and whatnot but if there's drugs
that's where I was going and I set you up and
you just you just sailed that ball through that
through the field goal yes yeah you saved
it we did it yeah I did it John started a
sports metaphor got lost in the basketball and you
brought it back to football yeah and I appreciate
that and hey I mean I I'm sure being from Scotland
you appreciate American football uh as much as we
do but I'm also sure that aside from all your drug
dealings yeah uh you probably know to appreciate
Nature's Most Bountiful medicine right because
you need that to knock down the drugs water
I mean you've got to put those you don't
want to put dry drug they need to be you know
um hydrated before they go in or after they go
in you wanna that way they're just like moving
through the bloodstream faster that's what
we want with drugs right that's how we do
the drugs I'm taking your advice yeah I am yeah
glacial water I am the water soul for this yeah
definitely and you and Daniel are going to guide
me into a a life of junkitude yeah so hey man
keep drinking that water with your drugs yeah and
stay pledged to the patreon it's important if you
if you run out of you know money for if you have
to choose between drugs and the patreon we hope
you choose the patreon oh oh oh right I meant
of patreon I meant the patreon buddy I meant
either way yeah he's drinking water totally
water I meant to actually say water [Music]